[Musique]
les pierres chaudes on est quel honte
j'ai fait le conservatoire national de
musique moi monsieur des celui c'est
tout ce que j'ai sur moi au hélas pas ok
prouve le mont garoua cette époque là
tout de suite je sui fra temps c'est
quoi tout ce bazar qu'est ce que tu
fumes avec sa seconde 90 e je le savais
vous avez tous lu vous êtes tous témoins
le soin j'ai menti
j'ai voulu que je fais ça et la
prochaine fois tu entropa plus petit
thouars talbot la la la bonté prémont
gran via je suis prêt déchets près
chaque habitant de cette ville a une
chance de devenir une star grâce à notre
concours de chant vous allez être
ébouriffés par le people hugh laurie
cholewa qui inquiète c'est comme à
l'aller
[Musique]
ça va au rugby très bien merci
fo si vous voulez devenir des stars et
gagner 100 mille dollars
vous allez devoir travailler plus dur
que vous ne l'avez jamais fait toute
votre vie
oui c'était très mauvais ou et johnny il
est pas là c'était une répétition
papa je veux pas faire partie de pong ce
que je veux c'est chanteur
comment j'ai fait pour avoir un fils
comme toile de fond sans tennis et
tennis chez toi tu comprendras que
l'arrivée ou non
celui-là qu'est ce qui se passe ici il
faut jamais c'est la peur nous empêcher
de faire ce qu'on aime c'est est ce
qu'il a bien quand on a touché le fond
c'est qu'il ne reste plus qu'une issue
on doit remonter
c'est mon fiston
elle est hyper du sel là ouais non c'est
clair je peux pas bouger terrorisés
allez sorte
je suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous êtes en train de répéter
cette fois c'est moi ils m'ont carrément
accusé d'être égocentrique
je sais même pas ce que ça veut tout
dire